am here to represent the parents who are
being portrayed as the enemy the super
spreaders the anti-science crew and now
most recently as domestic terrorists we
are here because we are defying these
illogical nonsensical one-sided
guidelines
we are parents and our job is to protect
our children
well a proposed masked ordinance failed
after parents spoke out at a charleston
city council meeting on school mass
mandates yesterday this is dozens of
parents protest is one of south
carolina's largest school districts over
a decision to move temporarily back to
virtual learning
due to a spike in coveted cases in the
classrooms amanda rollins is the mother
of a fourth grader in the pickens county
school district she joins us now from
home good morning to you amanda
good morning how are you i'm doing okay
so uh i know you're uh your fourth
grader has been back in school for
coming up on a couple of weeks now and
some
you know uh there currently are 142
students in the school district with
covid and so the school district decided
you know what we're just going to pull
the plug on in person for now people are
going to have to go home that's a
problem for you and other working
parents isn't it
it is it is
and so you decided to circulate a
petition
yes um
you know friday afternoon the school
district had an emergency closed door
meeting
and
decided the school board decided that it
was time to go virtual based on as you
said 142 students positive and
there were i think less than 30 teachers
positive um
the
the fact that it was so sudden and
the teachers didn't even know about this
meeting
um we found it at 4 30 friday afternoon
that we were going to be virtual
starting monday yeah and
um
you know it's we were in school for nine
days um and don't get me wrong i
understand covet i understand people get
sick and it's it can be very serious and
i want people to be safe of course
especially the kids but
there has to be a common ground between
pulling out everyone i mean there's
close to seventeen thousand students in
our school district
um
and i think this could be
done
much easier on a school-to-school basis
right so amanda you're
if if a particular
building has coveted you're fine with
them closing that down as long as the
kids can continue via zoom or whatever
but if a school doesn't have any covid
why close it that's what you're saying
exactly
well what about the the pickens county
school district did they consider that
honestly i'm not sure
um
over the weekend they sent an email out
to parents i believe it was sunday night
that said um
we've decided to
turn face to face on august 23rd this
coming monday
um and they're looking at their safety
protocols um to see what they can do
differently um
and and i'm all for that um like i said
i want everyone to be safe and
but also receive the quality education
that these kids deserve absolutely and
it's always better if the kids are in
the classrooms
the actual building
to see the teacher and everything else
but right now they've decided that's not
going to work out for them amanda thank
you very much uh for joining us today i
know you've got to uh your fourth grader
is in the other room you're gonna help
her start uh school here in just a
couple of minutes thank you yeah just a
little bit thanks have a good day you
bet you as well good luck hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now